in an nba career that spanned almost two
decades carmelo anthony has scored a lot
with 27 370 points only nine players
have scored more and anthony is still
playing his achievements while
impressive are no match for what it took
for this 10-time all-star to make it to
the nba that story is the subject of his
revealing new memoir
i spent eight years here and then every
summer until i was 15. on a recent visit
to red hook the brooklyn new york
neighborhood where life began for nba
great carmelo anthony the memories come
flooding back i was outside watching
and in the mix and people playing
basketball and i'm running on the court
you know i'm interrupting the game man
right i'm jumping off the monkey bars
and i watch my brother out the window
and just going outside trying to emulate
his moves it's those recollections and
stories from his childhood and
adolescence carmelo is sharing in his
memoir where tomorrows aren't promised i
want people to consider this like the
prequel to my career it's not a book
about basketball it's not a book about
basketball you know even though
basketball is the through line
throughout my whole life i just wanted
people to understand that i still had to
go through
everyday life
and focus on basketball that includes
growing up in two of america's toughest
neighborhoods with carmelo leaving the
projects of brooklyn when he was eight
for west baltimore he writes in red hook
they'd quickly kill you over disrespect
but in baltimore they'd kill you for
sport
y'all mind a crossfire here
let's go that grim reality was depicted
in the acclaimed hbo series the wire
people see the wire and they think well
that's hollywood's version no that's no
it's
the location
is the wire the why was something that
we really like that's us right there
that's a story about about us the end of
the first chapter you say the real
question was how did i a kid who had so
many hopes dreams and expectations
beaten out of him
make it here at all yes how did you
a little bit of luck oh more a little
bit of luck it was it was community
oriented i had to figure it out on my
own but also i had people pushing me you
know i had my community guided me family
guided me friends guided me you would
think that the guys who selling drugs
are on the block was making money those
are guys who would influence you to go
the other way but it was a total
opposite those guys always protected the
people in the neighborhood that needed
to be protected carmelo was named after
his father and was just two when his dad
died of cancer leaving carmelo's mother
mary to raise him starting here in an
apartment in the red hook west housing
project department 1c
it was the place i think is what you
want it was in and out all day long
uncles aunts in the house eight people
nine people in the three bedroom
apartment we fought over food we fought
over clothes we fought over where we're
sleeping at and that really kind of
created the bond where did that love
come from was it your mom
it was my mom and everybody knew
miss mary she was gonna do her thing she
was gonna cook she was clean she would
take care of you
outside those apartment walls carmelo's
older cousin luck became a guiding force
especially when it came to basketball
their late night games transformative
sitting under the lights and one o'clock
in the morning just outside me and him
you stepping over crack valves and crack
me and heroin needles and beer bottles
and prostitutes over here and drug
dealers over we talk about 1 a.m 2 a.m
but
that's what made me tougher i know in
the back of my mind
i got to get out of here like you see
what i got to walk back home through
that this is not for me i don't want
this no more
and while carmelo would get out
luck never did
he remembers their last night together
vividly and i remember like running to
the door after him like man don't leave
bro like don't please don't leave and we
get the call probably a couple hours
later they said luck is dead luck been
shot people don't understand what that
feeling is like to lose that and how you
feel after that it don't matter nothing
else matters no more you talk about how
it just felt like death was an
ever-present part of your life it's hard
explaining that and getting people to
understand that you start to lose hope
why am i here how much longer am i going
to be here i got to watch my back every
time i come outside so you just you're
surviving day to day
basketball was carmelo's escape i didn't
love it until
my junior year in high school
that's when he committed to play college
ball at syracuse university carmelo
finished high school at the prestigious
oak hill academy where he'd play in one
of the most anticipated basketball games
of the year a high school showdown
against fellow prep star lebron james
but for carmelo it was his time with
lebron off the court that truly stands
out when i tell you we sat there for
hours just talking it was nothing about
basketball you know i lost luck so i was
looking for
somebody to fill that void and to fill
that space and believe it or not he was
looking for someone to fill that void
and fill that space and we instantly
instantly connected carmelo would go on
to play one year at syracuse winning the
national championship as a freshman and
while he wanted to stay his head coach
jim behind was insistent it was time to
turn pro do you remember in that moment
where he said get out you gotta go
basically he didn't even tell me pack
nothing he just said get your stuff and
go i bet i see you back on this campus
and that's what we did the press
conference
um
just being here man
and i shed attend a press conference
like they
this is home it feels like feeling at
home matters to you it does there's no
better feeling than feeling like
you're home
being at peace being comfortable
there's no better feeling than that his
new home is in los angeles where he is
teaming up
with lebron james are you still friends
lebron james yes
i can wear a shirt
the last two active players from the
2003 nba draft that night is where his
book ends but carmelo's story is still
being written i think the timing is
right you know he had his path i had my
path we started together we're going in
together now you just said we're going
to end together is this like this our
career is like no no it just made it
like maybe like korea's coming to down
to the end while he's hoping that end
includes his first nba championship i
want people to feel inspired when they
when they look at this book it is clear
that carmelo anthony has already
exceeded the expectations set out for
most kids who are you ready are you
gonna pick you up
who start off here on these courts the
kids his memoir is dedicated to to every
child who knows there is more to this
life than what people tell them is
possible yes absolutely that was
i felt that the book is about hope and
survival and you know adversity and
overcoming obstacles
in these environments most kids nobody's
telling them what to do or how to do it
i just want people to understand like
that there's places
all over the world like that
tomorrow's on promise
you know i'm just telling you and he is
so revealing in this book and really
puts himself out there in a way that he
says you're taught not to do
on those streets where you're trying to
survive and it's okay to be vulnerable
like that it's a beautiful story so well
written and you can hear his voice
throughout it and you really connected
with him
well i think part of it was thank you
but i think it was reading that book and
those stories you feel like you connect
with him because he's been around but
these are stories he hasn't told before
and you feel like you understand him in
a different way and you feel like he's
ready to tell these stories yeah and he
tells them with such a plum i just i
really fell in love with him even more
so than you know
on the basketball listen the show
started with syracuse winning a
last-second field goal in football
a national championship so i'll take it
and and the opportunity to then go pro
yeah there it is